Dallas can you cut it out whatever you
guys were supposed to be cooked when Dad
got hurt now you're winning games with
Cooper Russia that's undefeated Cooper
rush to you one of the only undefeated
quarterbacks left this year yeah we know
Jalen's the other one well technically
there's one more our buddy from across
the pond Zach Wilson okay being 1-0
doesn't count also across the pond yeah
I think there are a few ponds in New
York you don't even play in New York
shut up anyway maybe Dallas being three
and one is a good thing why would that
be a good thing for you Cooper Rush
being undefeated and creating a
quarterback controversy that's the
perfect way to tear your team in fan
base apart oh come on there's not going
to be a controversy right because your
fans have never pushed for a talented
backup to take the job from an overpaid
starter what are you guys talking about
yeah what's going on nothing well hey at
least you guys can be happy about having
two of the top three quarterbacks in
this division you can't even give Daniel
Jones top three no what about Carson
Wentz Wentz is barely top 10 in this
Division I would take all three of our
starters and backups over here harsh but
fair all right who's ready for Taylor
heinecke season part four oh God not
again